Il y a tellement de contradictions.
Nous pleurons la morte tragique
d'Alan Kurdi, un enfant de deux ans,
et pourtant, depuis, plus de 200 enfants
se sont noyés dans la Méditerranée.
Des traités internationaux
reconnaissent que les réfugiés sont une responsabilité collective,
et pourtant nous acceptons que le petit Liban
accueille plus de Syriens que toute l'Europe réunie.
Nous nous lamentons sur l'existence de passeurs,
pourtant nous en faisons la seule route viable
pour chercher l'asile en Europe.
Il nous manque de la main d’œuvre,
pourtant nous empêchons les personnes
correspondant à nos besoins économiques et démographiques
de venir en Europe.
Nous proclamons nos valeurs libérales en opposition à l'Islam fondamentaliste,
pourtant --
nous avons des politiques de répression
qui arrêtent les demandeurs d'asile mineurs,
qui séparent les enfants de leur famille
et qui saisissent les biens des réfugiés.
Que faisons-nous ?
Comment en sommes-nous arrivés là,
à ce que nous adoptions une réponse si inhumaine à une crise humanitaire ?
Je ne crois pas que ce soit dû à un désintérêt,
tout du moins je ne veux pas le croire.
Je crois que c'est parce que nos politiciens n'ont pas de vision,
qu'ils ne savent pas adapter les règles international d'asile,
créées il y a plus de 50 ans,
à la mondialisation.
Je veux prendre du recul
et poser deux questions fondamentales,
les deux questions que nous devons tous poser.
Premièrement, pourquoi est-ce que le système actuel ne fonctionne-t-il pas ?
Secondement, comment pouvons-nous y remédier ?
Le régime actuel pour les réfugiés
a été créé suite aux conséquences de la Seconde Guerre Mondiale
par ces personnes.
Son but premier est d'assurer
que lorsqu'un État échoue, ou pire, se retourne contre son peuple,
les gens aient un endroit où aller,
où vivre en sécurité et avec dignité jusqu'à ce qu'ils puissent rentrer.
Il a été créé précisément pour des situations
telle que la situation actuelle en Syrie.
Au travers d'une convention internationale signée par 147 gouvernements,
la Convention relative au statut des réfugiés de 1951,
et une organisation internationale, le HCR,
les États se sont engagés à réciproquement admettre sur leur territoire
des personnes fuyant le conflit et la persécution.
Mais aujourd'hui, ce système échoue.
En théorie, les réfugiés ont le droit de demander l'asile.
En pratique, nos politiques d'immigration bloquent le chemin vers la sécurité.
En théorie, les réfugiés ont le droit à l'intégration
ou au retour dans leur pays d'origine.
Mais en pratique, ils restent coincés dans des limbes éternels.
En théorie, les réfugiés sont une responsabilité commune mondiale.
En pratique, la géographie fait que les pays proches du conflit
accueillent l'écrasante majorité des réfugiés.
Le système n'est pas cassé parce que les règles sont mauvaises
mais parce que nous ne les appliquons pas adéquatement à un monde qui change,
et c'est ce que nous devons reconsidérer.
Je vais vous expliquer comment fonctionne le système actuel.
Comment fonctionne l'actuel régime pour les réfugiés ?
Mais pas d'une perspective institutionnelle,
plutôt du point de vue d'un réfugié.
Imaginez une femme syrienne.
Appelons-la Amira.
Pour moi, Amira représente
beaucoup de personnes que j'ai rencontrées dans la région.
Amira, comme 25% des réfugiés dans le monde,
est une femme avec des enfants,
et elle ne peut pas rentrer chez elle car elle vient de cette ville
que vous voyez : Homs.
Une ville qui fut belle et historique
et qui est maintenant en ruines.
Amira ne peut pas y retourner.
Mais Amira n'a aucun espoir de s'installer dans un pays tiers,
parce qu'il y a une loterie
disponible à seulement moins de 1% des réfugiés.
Amira et sa famille
font face à un choix impossible.
Ils ont trois options.
La première option est qu'Amira emmène sa famille dans un camp.
Dans le camp, elle pourrait être aidée,
mais il y a peu d'avenir pour Amira et sa famille.
Les camps sont dans des lieux austères et arides,
souvent dans le désert.
Dans le camp Zaatari en Jordanie,
la nuit, vous entendez les bombardements de l'autre côté de la frontière.
L'activité économique est restreinte.
L'éducation est souvent de mauvaise qualité.
Dans le monde,
environ 80% des réfugiés qui sont dans des camps
doivent y rester au moins 5 ans.
C'est une vie misérable,
et c'est probablement la raison pour laquelle, en réalité,
seuls 9% des Syriens choisissent cette option.
Une alternative pour Amira est de se diriger vers la zone urbaine
d'un pays voisin, comme Amman ou Beyrouth.
C'est une option choisie par environ 75% des réfugiés syriens.
Mais elle comporte également des difficultés.
Les réfugiés dans de telles zones urbaines n'ont souvent pas le droit de travailler.
Ils n'ont souvent pas accès à de l'aide.
Et donc quand Amira et sa famille auront dépensé toutes leurs économies,
ils n'auront plus rien et seront dans la misère urbaine.
Il y a une troisième possibilité
que choisissent un nombre croissant de Syriens.
Amira peut chercher de l'espoir pour sa famille
en risquant leurs vies dans un voyage dangereux et périlleux
vers un autre pays,
et c'est ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui en Europe.
Nous offrons donc aux réfugiés un choix presqu'impossible
entre trois options :
le campement, la misère urbaine ou un voyage dangereux.
Pour les réfugiés, ce choix est le régime de réfugiés d'aujourd'hui.
Mais je crois que c'est un faux choix.
Nous pouvons reconsidérer ce choix.
La raison pour laquelle nous limitons ces options
est parce que nous pensons
que ce sont les seules options possibles pour les réfugiés,
mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Les politiques voient cela comme un problème à somme nulle,
si nous avantageons les réfugiés, les citoyens en paient le prix.
Nous avons tendance à penser
que les réfugiés sont un coût inévitable ou un poids pour la société.
Mais ils n'ont pas à l'être. Ils peuvent contribuer.
Ce que je veux dire,
c'est qu'il y a des façon d'augmenter les possibilités
et que tout le monde en bénéficie :
les pays et communautés d'accueil,
nos sociétés et les réfugiés.
Et je veux suggérer quatre façons
de transformer notre vision des réfugiés.
Ces quatre points de vue ont une chose en commun :
ils incluent les opportunités de la mondialisation,
de la mobilité et des marchés,
et modernisent notre façon de penser au problème des réfugiés.
La première idée
est celle des environnements favorables.
Cela commence avec la reconnaissance fondamentale
que les réfugiés sont des êtres humains comme tout le monde,
mais avec des circonstances extraordinaires.
Avec mes collègues d'Oxford,
nous nous sommes lancés dans un projet de recherche en Ouganda,
observant la vie économique des réfugiés.
Nous avons choisi l'Ouganda,
non pas car il est représentatif de tous les pays d'accueil.
Il est exceptionnel.
Contrairement à la majorité des pays d'accueil,
l'Ouganda a donné
une opportunité économique aux réfugiés.
Il leur donne le droit de travailler, la liberté de se déplacer.
Et les résultats en sont extraordinaires,
pour les réfugiés et pour la communauté d'accueil.
Dans la capitale, Kampala,
nous avons découvert que 21% des réfugiés possèdent un commerce employant des gens
et 40% de ces employés
sont des natifs du pays d'accueil.
En d'autres mots, les réfugiés créent du travail
pour les citoyens du pays d'accueil.
Même dans les camps, nous avons découvert des exemples extraordinaires
d'entreprises dynamiques et florissantes.
Par exemple, dans un village du nom de Nakivale,
nous avons l'exemple de réfugiés congolais
dirigeant des entreprises de partage digital de musique.
Nous avons trouvé un Rwandais qui dirige une entreprise
pour permettre aux jeunes de jouer aux jeux vidéo
sur des consoles et des télévisions recyclées.
Malgré les difficultés des contraintes extrêmes,
les réfugiés innovent
et l'homme que vous voyez est un Congolais du nom de Demou-Kay.
Demou-Kay est arrivé dans le campement avec très peu de biens,
mais il voulait devenir réalisateur.
Donc, avec des amis et des collègues,
il a lancé une station de radio communautaire,
il a loué une caméra
et réalise des films.
Il a réalisé deux documentaires
avec et pour notre équipe
et il est en train de créer une entreprise prospère avec presque rien.
Ce sont ce genre d'exemples
qui devraient guider notre réponse envers les réfugiés.
Plutôt que de voir les réfugiés
comme inévitablement dépendants de l'aide humanitaire,
nous devons leur fournir l'opportunité d'un développement humain.
Oui, des habits, des couvertures, un abri, de la nourriture
sont très importants dans la phase d'urgence,
mais nous devons aller plus loin.
Nous devons offrir l'opportunité de la connectivité, l'électricité,
l'éducation, le droit de travailler,
l'accès aux banques.
Tout ce que nous considérons comme acquis,
qui nous intègre dans l'économie mondiale
peut et devrait être offert aux réfugiés.
La seconde idée dont je veux parler est les zones économiques.
Malheureusement, tous les pays d'accueil du monde
n'ont pas l'approche qu'a l'Ouganda.
La plupart des pays d'accueil n'ouvrent pas leur économie aux réfugiés
de cette façon.
Mais il y a toujours des options pragmatiques que nous pouvons utiliser.
En avril dernier, je suis allé en Jordanie avec mon collègue,
l'économiste du développement, Paul Collier,
et nous avons réfléchi à une idée que nous avons eue là-bas
avec la communauté internationale et le gouvernement,
une idée pour créer des emplois pour les Syriens
tout en soutenant la stratégie nationale de développement de la Jordanie.
C'est l'idée d'une zone économique
où nous pourrions potentiellement intégrer l'emploi des réfugiés
ainsi que l'emploi des natifs du pays d'accueil.
A 15 minutes du camp Zaatari,
qui héberge 83 000 réfugiés,
il y a la zone de développement du roi Hussein Bin Talal.
Le gouvernement a dépensé plus de 100 millions de dollars
pour la relier au réseau électrique et au réseau routier,
mais il manquait deux choses :
l'accès à la main d’œuvre et aux investissements étrangers
afin que les réfugiés puissent travailler là-bas
plutôt que d'être bloqués dans des camps,
soutenir leur famille,
développer des compétences grâce à une formation professionnelle
avant de retourner en Syrie.
Nous avons reconnu que la Jordanie en bénéficierait,
sa stratégie de développement nécessitant de passer le pas
d'un pays à revenu moyen à un pays industriel.
Les réfugiés en bénéficieraient mais cela contribuerait aussi
à la reconstruction de la Syrie après la guerre,
en reconnaissant que nous devons incuber les réfugiés
car ils sont la meilleure ressource pour reconstruire la Syrie.
Nous avons publié cette idée dans la revue Foreign Affairs.
Le roi Abdullah a repris l'idée.
Cela a été annoncé à la conférence de Londres sur la Syrie
et un test commencera durant l'été.
(Applaudissements)
La troisième idée que je veux vous soumettre
est la notion de préférence entre les États et les réfugiés
menant à des résultats positifs que vous voyez dans ce selfie
où figurent Angela Merkel et un réfugié syrien.
Nous demandons rarement aux réfugiés ce qu'ils veulent, où ils veulent aller,
mais nous pouvons le faire
et ce sera mieux pour tout le monde.
L'économiste Alvin Roth a développé l'idée de l'adéquation des marchés,
où l'ordre de préférence des parties détermine leur éventuelle correspondance.
Mes collègues Will Jones et Alex Teytelboym
ont cherché des façons d'appliquer cette idée aux réfugiés,
de demander aux réfugiés de classer les destinations
mais également de permettre aux États de classer le type de réfugiés souhaités
sur des critères de compétences ou de langues,
puis de les faire correspondre.
Bien sûr, il faudrait mettre en place des quotas
quant à la diversité et la vulnérabilité,
mais c'est une façon d'augmenter les chances de correspondance.
L'idée de correspondance est utilisée avec succès
pour, par exemple, répartir les étudiants à l'université,
faire correspondre les donneurs de rein et les patients,
et l'algorithme existe sur les sites de rencontre.
Pourquoi ne pas appliquer cela pour offrir le choix aux réfugiés ?
Cela pourrait aussi être utilisé au niveau national
où l'un des plus grands défis
est de persuader les communautés locales d'accepter des réfugiés.
Actuellement, dans mon pays, par exemple,
nous envoyons souvent
des ingénieurs en zone rurale et des fermiers en ville,
ce qui n'a aucun sens.
Les marchés en adéquation permettent de réunir ces préférences
et d'écouter les besoins et demandes de la population d'accueil
et des réfugiés.
La quatrième idée dont je veux parler est le principe de visa humanitaire.
Les tragédies et les désordres observés en Europe
auraient pu être évités.
Ils proviennent d'une contradiction fondamentale
dans la politique européenne sur l'asile :
afin de demander l'asile en Europe,
vous devez arriver spontanément en embarquant dans un voyage dangereux
dont j'ai déjà parlé.
Mais pourquoi ces voyages sont-ils nécessaires
à l'ère des compagnies aériennes low-cost
et des moyens consulaires modernes ?
Ces voyages ne sont pas nécessaires
et, l'année dernière, ils ont mené à la mort de plus de 3 000 personnes
aux frontières de l'Europe et sur le territoire européen.
Si les réfugiés avaient le droit
de voyager directement et de demander l'asile en Europe,
nous éviterions cela.
Et nous pouvons faire cela
grâce aux visas humanitaires
qui permettent aux gens d'obtenir un visa d'une ambassade
ou d'un consulat d'un pays voisin
puis en payant leur trajet
en ferry ou en avion jusqu'à l'Europe.
Cela coûte environ 1 000 €
de payer un passeur de la Turquie vers les îles grecques.
Un vol low-cost de Bodrum à Francfort coûte 200 €.
Si nous autorisions les réfugiés, cela aurait des avantages majeurs.
Cela sauverait des vies,
cela amoindrirait le marché des passeurs
et marquerait la fin du désordre observé en première ligne européenne
dans des zones comme les îles grecques.
Ce sont les lois qui nous en empêchent et non une solution rationnelle.
C'est une idée qui a été appliquée.
Le Brésil a adopté une approche avant-gardiste
et plus de 2 000 Syriens ont obtenu des visas humanitaires,
sont allés au Brésil et, à leur arrivée, ont demandé le statut de réfugié.
Dans cette configuration, chaque Syrien qui a fait cela
a reçu le statut de réfugié et a été reconnu comme étant un réfugié.
Il y a un précédent historique.
Entre 1922 et 1942,
ces passeports Nansen ont été utilisés comme documents de voyage
autorisant 450 000 Assyriens, Turcs et Tchétchènes
à voyager en Europe
et à demander le statut de réfugié ailleurs en Europe.
Et le Bureau International des Réfugiés de Nansen
a reçu le prix Nobel de la Paix
en reconnaissance envers cette stratégie viable.
Chacune de ces quatre idées que je vous ai présentées
sont des façons d'étendre les choix d'Amira.
Ce sont des moyens que nous avons d'augmenter le choix des réfugiés
au-delà de ces options, ces trois impossibles options
que je vous ai détaillées,
tout en bénéficiant aux autres.
En conclusion, nous avons besoin d'une nouvelle perspective
une vision qui étend le choix des réfugiés
mais reconnaît qu'ils n'ont pas à être un fardeau.
Il n'y a rien d'inévitable dans le fait que les réfugiés soient un coût.
Oui, ils sont une responsabilité humanitaire,
mais ils sont des êtres humains avec des compétences, talents, aspirations
et la capacité de contribuer, si nous le leur permettons.
Dans le nouveau monde,
la migration ne s'arrêtera pas.
Ce que nous avons vu en Europe continuera pendant des années.
Les gens voyageront encore,
les populations seront déplacées
et nous devons trouver des façons rationnelles et réalistes de le gérer,
non pas basées sur les vieilles logiques de l'aide humanitaire,
de la charité,
mais bâties sur les opportunités
offertes par la mondialisation, les marchés et la mobilité.
Je vous presse de vous réveiller et je presse nos politiciens
de se réveiller face à ce défi.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)